so we've spent a lot of time justifying
why we have this downward sloping demand
curve for money but you're probably
asking well this is a market what we
need to think about an equilibrium point
and to do that we need to think about
the supply of money and in previous
videos we've started thinking about the
supply of money and we'll think more in
future videos about different monetary
policies but in a classical model we
assume a perfectly inelastic supply of
money so we draw it as a vertical line
which is another way of saying that the
supply of money is not impacted by the
nominal interest rate so this is the
supply of money i'll call that money
supply one where it intersects the
quantity of money i'll just call that m
sub 1 right over here and so this point
where it intersects is the equilibrium
point in our money market the
equilibrium nominal interest rate right
over here we could call
r1 this would be the opportunity cost
for holding money now i have to give a
little bit of a disclaimer this is a
classical model here and we'll talk more
about it in future videos and most
introductory economics class talk about
this classical model where the central
bank might set the supply of money and
that doesn't change according to the
nominal interest rate and then the
nominal interest rate gets set
essentially by this equilibrium point
now in the world that we live in it
actually goes the other way around
central banks actually target a nominal
interest rate and if the central bank is
able to achieve that target interest
rate well that's going to impact the
actual quantity of money so keep that
little disclaimer in the back of your
mind but in an introductory economics
class we assume this world so now that
we have this neat little model for our
money market let's think about what
would happen in different situations
let's think about a situation where for
whatever reason people lose confidence
in the electrical grid what would happen
to the demand curve for money and let's
call this the md sub 1. pause this video
and think about it
well if people lose trust in the
electrical grid then this precautionary
motive for holding money becomes
stronger regardless of what the
opportunity cost is of holding money
people would want to hold more of it
because like hey you know i don't know
if i'll be able to access money if the
lights go out again i'm not going to be
able to go to atm or the banks are going
to close and so at any nominal interest
rate i would
or an aggregate people and are going to
want to hold more money and so that
would shift the demand curve for money
to the right
i could have drawn it a little less
hairy but there you go that would be m
d sub 2. we have this shift to the right
and then if that happened if you had
this demand for money increase well then
what happens to the actual equilibrium
nominal interest rate if you look at
this point right over here assuming that
the quantity of money has not changed
you have a new equilibrium interest rate
nominal interest rate it has gone up and
that makes sense if more people want to
hold money in order for in order to get
people to part with that money you have
to offer them more the opportunity cost
of holding that money has to go up and
you can imagine the reverse scenario if
for some reason people thought it's a
lot less likely that the lights are
going to go out or they said you know i
don't need as much cash around for
transactions or i'm not really into
speculation well then the demand curve
for money would shift to the left and in
that situation you would have a decrease
in the equilibrium nominal interest rate
i will leave you there always keep these
models with a grain of salt there are
simplifications of the real world
especially here where we're assuming a
perfectly inelastic supply of money
which actually isn't the case in the
real world but we can go with this for
just for for the purposes of starting to
study the money market